voilà pour les faits aujourd'hui notre
invité ce soir c'est monsieur claude
evin le ministre de la solidarité de la
santé monsieur et 20 avant d'en venir
aux propositions qui ont été refusées
vous l'avez entendu tout à l'heure dans
le reportage
j'aurais que vous nous parler un peu de
votre position ce soir d'un côté les
infirmières passe au dessus de vous sans
s'en réfère directement chef de l'état
le chef de l'état comprend la plainte
des français 1017 au gouvernement de
gérer cette affaire
c'est en effet au gouvernement d'en
assumer la responsabilité je crois que
le président de la république l'a
lui-même confirmé et d'ailleurs depuis
quinze jours le gouvernement discute
écoute les infirmières il écoute les
organisations syndicales des coutelas
coordination il écoute l'union des
associations lui nassif et j ai
personnellement passé beaucoup d'heures
jour nuit mon cabinet aussi nous avons
beaucoup écouté quand vous restez
l'interlocuteur je suis le ministre en
charge de ce dossier
c'est un dossier qui dépend plus de la
fonction publique hospitalière je suis
en responsabilité sur ce dossier en
effet alors revenons-en aux chiffres qui
ont été avancés
la revendication le rappel des
infirmières est 2000 francs en
augmentation uniforme
vous vous proposez 595 francs bruts au
départ pour les infirmière débutante
augmentation de 8% 764 francs pour une
infirmière au bout de six ans c'est à
dire 9 % d'augmentation et au terme de
15 ans 16% d'augmentation 1536 francs
est ce qu'on peut aller au delà de ça
dans la négociation je connais la
revendication des infirmières je connais
aussi leurs problèmes d'ailleurs je suis
moi-même président d'un conseil
d'administration d'un centre hospitalier
général à saint nazaire ça fait 14 ans
que je préside ce conseil
d'administration je connais bien ce
problème sur les salaires d'abord mais
il n'ya pas que le problème des salaires
dans ce que posent les infirmiers et
l'entente du premier statut de chevet
revenir tout à l'heure elles ont un
statut les infirmières dans le cadre du
statut de la fonction publique
hospitalière et les propositions que
nous avons reformulé revalorise ce
statut alors allé au delà en matière de
rémunération ce n'est pas possible
pourquoi c'est pas possible c'est pas
qu'on ne voudrait pas aller au delà
c'est que aller au delà se serait payé
les augmentations en monnaie de singe
ça veut dire qu'on prendrait le risque
que l'inflation mordent ces
augmentations et les infirmières
elle-même n'y gagnerait pas
et puis il ya les autres salariés de la
fonction publique les autres salariés
dans notre pays il n'est pas possible de
dérivés sur l'ensemble des salaires
voilà pourquoi le gouvernement ne peut
pas aller au delà
alors je veux bien que dans votre
affaire la difficulté qu'il ya dans
cette affaire c'est que d'un côté vous
n'avez pas à faire là directement aux
syndicats mais une coordination et
est-ce que vous avez la possibilité de
négociations dans l'impression de de la
part des infirmiers une position sur
laquelle on ne transige pas comment
allez vous pouvoir vous sortir de cette
affaire c'est bien la difficulté de
négocier avec la coordination qui depuis
le début reste bloquée figé sur sa
position de 2000 francs une négociation
c'est la recherche d'un compromis et on
ne peut pas passer un compromis avec la
coordination qui est resté depuis le
départ sur les 2000 francs je souhaite
que l'on sorte le plus rapidement
possible de ce conflit mais il est
nécessaire de rapprocher les points de
vue et je constate que la coordination y
compris encore aujourd'hui sur 2000
francs et que pouvez vous faire vous
pour tenter de rapprocher les points de
vue est ce que vous n'avez pas d'une
certaine façon au départ un peu négligé
cette coordination j'ai pas du tout
négliger cette coordination j'ai vu
beaucoup beaucoup vous avez reçu les
syndicats dans un premier temps vous ne
receviez que les syndicats non non non
non non non je rappelle que dès le
premier jour mon directeur de cabinet a
reçu la coordination régionale
ile-de-france le développement des
coordinations aujourd'hui si nous
assistions de nouveau à ce problème je
souhaite bien du courage à tous mes
collègues ministres ministre des ptt
ministre des transports avec la sncf ou
autre j'allais vous dire là il y à une
dépêche qui est tombé vers 19h20 le
comité national de liaison des cheminots
lance un appel à la mobilisation
générale entre le 17 et 21 octobre
on se retrouve dans un peu dans la
position de monsieur chirac l'hiver 86
96 avec sexy coordination de cheminots
là encore on se retrouve avec autre
chose comme interlocuteur d'autres
personnes que les syndicalistes
oui ce problème ces coeurs pose de
graves questions au mouvement syndical
il lui appartient de le gérer de le
traiter
le gouvernement doit écouter le
gouvernement ils écoutent tous ceux qui
s'expriment j'ai écouté la coordination
j'y ai passé de nombreuses heures avec
la coordination depuis maintenant 15
jours
mais discuter arriver à un accord
c'est donc recherché ce sur quoi on peut
avancer ce sur quoi il n'est pas
possible d'avancer on en discute avec la
coordination j'ai aussi discuté ils
m'ont dit beaucoup de choses ils ont
beaucoup exprimer ce qu'ils ressentent
ce qui les attire bien ressentent c'est
un ras-le-bol c'est vrai et elles
attendent des réponses sur les salaires
je me suis exprimé sur la formation et
sur les conditions de travail
je les ai entendu tout à l'heure ce que
je voudrais dire sur la formation et sur
les conditions de travail
c'est que j'ai pris des engagements j'ai
pris des engagements que je tiendrais
mais je ne peux pas résoudre ces
problèmes en huit jours parce que ce
sont des problèmes compliqués qui ne
trouvent pas de solution en huit jours
mais j'apporterai des réponses sur ces
problèmes qu'elles ont posé monsieur je
vous remercie